المزيد من التفاصيل عن الحديث الامريكي عن
ان هذه الضربات حققت اهدافها وكيفيه تفاعل
رد حركه انصار الله بانها سترد على هذه
الضربات نعم هناك معلومات ومعطيات جديده
تكشفت اليوم خلال احاطه انتهت قبل قليل من
قبل مدير هيئه الاركان المشتركه في القوات
الامريكيه الجنرال سيمز الذي اشار الى ان
الضربات التي وجهتها كل من الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا لمواقع تابعه لانصار
الله الحوثيين في اليمن تمت على دفعتين
خلال الدفعه الاولى جر استهداف 16 موقعا
مختلفا فوق الاراضي اليمنيه وكل موقع يضم
اهداف متعدده وانه بعد هذه الموجه الاولى
بنحو 30 دقيقه الى 60 دقيقه جرت تعرف على
12 موقعا اضافيا قدرت القوات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه ان انصار الله الحوثيين قد
يمتلكون فيها
اسلحه يمكن ان تهدد القوات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه البحريه والجويه في المنطقه
وبالتالي جرى استهداف كل هذه المواقع
الجنرال سيمز قال ان هذه الضربات لم تكن
مخصصه بالضروره لايقاع اصابات بين مقاتلي
واعضاء انصار الله الحوثيين انما تقويد
قدراتهم على شن المزيد من الهجمات وعرقله
الملاحه البحريه في البحر الاحمر وفي هذا
السياق هو اعرب عن الثقه بان الضربات
اصابت اهدافها بان قدره الحوثيين على شن
هجمات واسعه جرى تقويضها ولكن قال ان
عمليه التقيييم الشامله لم تنتهي بعد اما
فيما يتعلق بردود الحوثيين قال ان القوات
الامريكيه رصدت اليوم هجوما واحدا شنه
الحوثيون ردا على هذه الضربات من خلال
صاروخ بالستي مضاد للسفن لم يصب اي هدف هو
اعرب على الاعتقاد بان الحوثيين ربما لا
يزال زالوا يقومون بعمليه تقييم للاضرار
التي لحقت بقدراتهم لكنه توقع بان يحاولوا
ان يوجهوا ضربات انتقاميه وفي هذا الاطار
ترك الباب مفتوحا امام عمليات عسكريه
امريكيه اضافيه ضد مواقعهم قال ان القوات
الامريكيه سوف تكون جاهزه وهو بعث برساله
واضحه لايران حيث قال ان ايران تمتلك
نفوذا على الحوثيين ان انصار الله
الحوثيين يستمعون الى ايران وينبغي ان
يدركوا بان كل هذه الاعمال لن تاتي باي
فائده عليهم انا طرحت سؤال حول كيف ستنعكس
هذه الضربات التي قالت الولايات المتحده
انها مخصصه عمليا لشل قدره الحوثيين عن
استهداف الملاحه البحريه في البحر الاحمر
وباب المندب خصوصا ان اليوم ثلاث شركات
شحن للنفط اعلنت عن توقيف عملياتها قال ان
في الواقع هناك حتى هذه اللحظه 12 شركه
معنيه بالشحن البحري اوقفت عملياتها
بالكامل او حدت منها لكنه لم يقدم ايجابه
واضحه تربط ما بين هذه الضربات وبين
الاثار على تعزيز الامن في البحر الاحمر
شك اشكرك من البنتاجون مراسلنا فادي منصور